[Music]
so
excuse me what about the alt left they
came charging at the
as you say the alt-right do they have
any
semblance of guilt a local world war ii
veteran wants you to hear and see this
next story because he's worried
what he fought against so long ago is
making a comeback
here in the united states he believes
what happened
hi in this video i'm going to talk about
how to recognize a fascist
[Music]
to begin let's take a look at what
fascism is
contemporary fascists share three core
beliefs
one people of european heritage are
ought to constitute a biological
cultural and political unity known as
the white race sometimes dog-whistled as
western culture
two jews are masterminding the
destruction of the white race through
multiculturalism and non-white
immigration
a plot that fascists call white genocide
or ethnic replacement
three the only way to save the white
race is to establish a white homeland
or ethno state from which non-whites and
degenerates must be purged
now as i've argued in past videos all
three of these beliefs are false
so what is it that's attracting people
to fascism well
let's take a look at a contemporary nazi
propaganda video
and see if we can figure that out
who are you
i'm not talking about your name or your
occupation
i'm talking about something bigger
something deeper
i'm talking about your connection to a
culture
a history a destiny
our ancestors had a very strong sense of
their identity
they could say i'm a roman
i'm a saxon i'm a dane
good news boys you no longer have to be
some schlubby [ __ ] riding the escalator
at ikea
thinking about how much you hate your
job as a marketing and communications
associate
because the sun hath risen on the day
wherein you take your father's claymore
in hand
and defend voltaire and adorable blonde
children against
black civil rights you know just like
the vikings dead
we're often told that being an american
or a briton or
german or any european nationality is
about being dedicated to a collection
of abstractions and buzzwords
democracy freedom tolerance
multiculturalism but a nation
based on freedom is just another place
to go
shopping so life
is basically sad and in capitalist
society that sadness is a sense of
isolation
and anxiety that there's nothing more to
life than acquiring 1990s collector's
edition tampa bay buccaneers
slim jim beersteins until you die
fortunately thanks to fascism you don't
have to
fascism promises you apart in something
greater than yourself
a homeland for your people a sense of
belonging to a tradition that stretches
back
thousands of years and as far into the
future just be sure to be extra proud of
the parts of your heritage that involve
buying and selling other human beings as
property the most basic way to resist
fascism is to recognize its propaganda
for what it is
the idea that appreciating european
culture is in some way linked to
establishing a white ethnostate is just
nonsense
your enjoyment of beethoven or white
babies or whatever it is you get off to
is in no way impeded by the proximity of
people with different skin colors and
traditions
and it certainly does not require nation
culture and geographic ancestry to all
become the same thing
but in order to recognize fascism you
need to do a lot more than reject the
most overt propaganda
in the wake of the disastrous alt-right
rally in charlottesville earlier this
month
the nazis have been driven back into the
shadows at least two of their major
websites were shut down
confederate monuments were removed all
over the country and several prominent
fascists have begun
backpedaling none of this means fascists
will go away
it just means they'll have to be more
subtle and indirect shortly after the
charlottesville rally
a post titled fixing the alt-right
appeared on pole
the image board where millennial nazis
talk strategy and trade pictures of
japanese nymphats
the post outlines some basic fascist
strategy
don't get trapped in an echo chamber
where you can no longer relate to
normies
pretending that charlottesville didn't
massively push the average white person
away
is really stupid we have a chance to
actually make changes now that trump has
shifted the overton window to the right
but we need to be smart and make the
movement appealing to the average white
person
and the way to do that is disavow all
nazi
kkk edgelord larpers there is no way to
lose public support quicker than going
around making nazi salutes and holding
tiki torches while chanting jews will
not replace us
this instantly makes the average person
hate you
build a populist movement with realistic
incremental
overt goals repealing the 1965
immigration act and replacing it with
something that both limits total
immigration and prioritizes
white immigration is an actual tangible
political goal
keep the long-term goals covert and
don't ever reveal your power level
talking openly about a white ethno state
only leads to failure and the average
public turning against you
so disavow anyone who reveals his power
level
leftists will recognize dog whistles and
nowhere crypto
but normies won't listen to them so at
first glance this seems like a really
silly juvenile post that references
dragon ball z
but it actually displays a sense of
realistic pragmatism
and an incremental approach to long-term
goals that i wish were more common on
the left
but of course the strategy described
here isn't new older generations of
white supremacists have been doing this
stuff for decades when overt racism is
politically unacceptable
politicians have to use coded language
in order to appeal to racists
republican strategist lee atwater
explained the technique in an interview
in 1981.
you start out in 1954 by saying
by 1968 you can't say that hurts
you backfires so you say stuff like
force bussing
states rights and all that stuff you're
getting so abstract now that
you're talking about cutting taxes and
all these things that you're talking
about are totally economic things and a
byproduct of them
is that blacks get hurt worse than
whites
so if you want to recognize a fascist
you have to know how to read subtext and
how to hear dog whistles
because 99 times out of 100 a fascist
will disavow fascism racism and white
supremacy
at least when talking to you a
non-fascist rallies with swastikas and
nazi salutes are the exception
not the rule fascists are more likely to
gain traction
and are hence more dangerous when they
use subtler tactics so for the rest of
this video i'll be describing the
particular strategies that fascists use
to code their ideas
and make them more palatable to
conservatives centrists and liberals
strategy one outright denial never
reveal your power level
disavow anyone who reveals their power
level this means that if someone acts
like a fascist
has fascist beliefs repeats fascist
talking points
and hangs out with other fascists the
fact that they publicly denounce
fascism should be worth absolutely
nothing to you and shouldn't even enter
into your consideration of whether
they're a fascist
after all i'm not a fascist is exactly
what a fascist would say
strategy 2 euphemism of course i'm not a
fascist
i'm an alternative ethno-nationalist
simply trying to preserve western values
fascists constantly shift their
terminology in order to avoid the
negative connotations that develop
around the names of their movements
whenever people figure out what they
really are
so they insist they are nazis or white
supremacists just white nationalists or
alt-right but as people catch on to the
fact that white nationalists and the
alt-right are just nazis they'll shift
their terminology again
and start telling you i'm not a white
nationalist i'm an identitarian
or whatever the next thing is but it's
still the same bastards they're just
using a different name
they'll also use euphemisms for core
components of their beliefs
if talking about preserving a homeland
for white people sounds too fascist
they'll talk about preserving western
civilization or western culture
instead if the phrase white genocide
discredits them they'll say ethnic
replacement instead and if it's
considered hate speech to advocate
purging non-white people
they'll talk instead about purging
immigrants criminals rapists and
terrorists
and leave it to the audience to catch
the color coding on their own
strategy 3 pedentry it's absurd to call
me a nazi
the german national socialist party
hasn't existed since 1945.
that's right and i bet he's an
isolationist too not an expansionist
like the nazis
fascists use this kind of selective
pedantry to dodge derogatory labels
and also to bog you down in a petty
terminological dispute this is a good
way to waste your time
divert your attention away from whatever
led you to call them a nazi in the first
place
i'm not a white supremacist i don't
think that whites are superior to other
races
i simply think we deserve a homeland of
our own as
do all peoples there it is again and
next he's going to tell us that since
asians have the highest iqs he's if
anything
an asian supremacist and then you'll get
sucked into arguing about iq
instead of talking about the fact that
the main goal of the politics he
supports
is the political and social supremacy of
white people over all
other americans and europeans in other
words white supremacy
strategy four secret symbols nazis have
always taken an interest in occult
symbols like the black sun
on fritz's ring more like the swastika
itself but more obscure symbols can be
useful as a kind of secret handshake
that lets nazis recognize each other
without normies taking notice
the best symbols to use for this purpose
are ones that are not primarily
associated with fascism
or at least have some other meaning such
as the athala rune or the iron cross
better still are symbols that until
adoption by fascists
are completely innocuous modern fascists
have taken to using almost arbitrary
emoji as a way to wink and nod at each
other
notably the frog after pepe the milk
and the okay sign so it doesn't matter
what the symbols are
in fact it's important that the symbols
constantly change so that normies don't
catch on
by the time you watch this video they
probably won't even be using the frog
anymore
maybe it'll be this or this the only way
to find out is to watch fascists
carefully and see what symbols they use
to identify themselves
and of course another advantage of using
innocuous symbols
is that when leftists try to point those
symbols out the fascists can always say
these gullible sjws now think that even
the okay
sign is racist is there anything they
don't think is racist
and the gullible centrists will be taken
right in
the poor centrists they're so afraid
that antifa is going to punch them
because of their hair or their emoji
and you know some leftists are [ __ ]
or idiots so
i should say you should never assume
someone is a fascist
just because of their hair or because of
the emoji they use
these are only little pieces of a larger
puzzle but white centrists also need to
understand
that the way you feel about antifa
political rallies oh god what if they
profile me and attack me unfairly
that's how a lot of black people feel
about the police all the time
and the fascists whose free speech you
defend so often are trying to drum up
exactly the sentiments that make the
police dangerous to black people
and that make it dangerous for queer
people to be themselves in public
so i hope that's something you think
about anyway it's not that the ok
sign is inherently racist or that anyone
who uses it is racist
and in fact it's its very innocuousness
that makes it useful as a cryptofascist
wink and nudge but the misunderstanding
about calling these little things racist
sets the stage for
strategy 5 camaraderie of the accused
the left accuses everyone of racism they
think all white people are nazis
if it's acceptable to attack and censor
me they'll come for you
next fascists have very effectively
exploited the general hostility towards
social justice warriors
especially online unfortunately not all
leftists have my connoisseur's eye for
detecting fascism
and some of them do throw the label at
centrists or liberals
this doesn't cause centrists to become
allied with fascists
history shows that happens regardless
but it can accelerate the process
lending some plausibility to the fear
that moderate centrists have
that anti-fascists will come after them
next it's tactically smart for fascists
to make the most of this situation
and use it to pump up sympathy and
solidarity from centrists
strategy six irony jokes satire
and meetings of course i wasn't actually
being racist
it was just an edgy meme can't anyone
take a joke anymore or will the antifa
fascists violently attack you over humor
now too
here's a uniquely millennial twist on
the racist dog whistle
you shroud your sincere ideas and
cartoon characters and memes
and then when called out you mock your
accuser for being a clueless
normie who isn't in on the joke
sometimes irony can be a safe way to
explore ideas that you're not quite
ready to own yet
before i realized i was transgender i
used to jump at any opportunity to
crossdress
ironically so when you see people joking
about being nazis
they could just be joking or they could
be using irony to partially conceal the
truth
it's difficult to tell the difference
and that's the point
but kekastan is just a satire of
identity politics
well it's a hilarious satire of civil
rights movements that just happens to
use a nazi battle flag
and while it may have been popularized
originally by god damn centrist
youtubers who are unable or unwilling to
see how helpful they're being to
fascists
kekistan became the perfect
pseudo-ironic pretext for
uh identitarians including the ones who
led the rally where an edgy [ __ ] poster
hilariously memed his car into a crowd
of people
no wonder the splc now describes it as a
hate symbol
those normie fools it's just a joke
strategy 7 shifting blame why doesn't
the mainstream media cover violent
anti-white organizations
like black lives matter or antifa this
is essentially just a two-co-que fallacy
especially heinous because of the
equivocation between fascist violence
and anti-fascist violence
and between white nationalism and black
civil rights the implication is that
activism to reduce urban poverty or
violence against black people
is just the mirror image of white
supremacist ethnic cleansing
shortly after the charlottesville
incident our proto-fascist president
called out antifa in the alt-left a term
fascists invented to distract liberals
and centrists
and establish the assumption that there
must be some leftist equivalent of the
alt-right
because if you have a word for a thing
that thing must exist
both sides rhetoric is useful to
fascists because it diverts attention
away from them
vilifies anti-fascists wins sympathy
from centrists
and helps to shift the center of
acceptable discourse in their direction
strategy eight incrementalism you don't
have to support a white ethnic state to
want common sense policies about
immigration
of course i don't support violence
against the non-white people already
here
but we do have a right to preserve our
boundaries in our culture don't we
the common thread in all fascist
strategies is deception and manipulation
often aimed at representing what is
essentially an attack on non-white
people
as a defense of white people in white
culture the fascist's long-term goal is
a homogeneous ethnostate
which at some point will require massive
ethnic cleansing of one kind or another
but of course they won't tell you about
that unless they think you're also a
fascist
the strategic fascist knows it's better
to start with realistic
achievable goals and that means focusing
first on stopping non-white immigration
something they'll try to get you the
centrist conservative or liberal
on board with by emphasizing the danger
and criminality
of non-white immigrants and refugees if
they can whip up enough racist sentiment
with that rhetoric
they can later turn that energy against
the non-white people who are already
here
strategy 9 the free speech defense
you may not agree with what i say but i
have just as much a right to speak and
assemble as anyone else
much of anti-fascist strategy involves
limiting fascists ability to publicly
recruit and intimidate
often by shutting down fascist marches
and rallies or by pressuring platforms
not to host
fascists the best way for the fascists
to oppose that strategy
is to appeal to the liberal value of
free speech nothing tugs on those
classical liberal heartstrings like a
tale of woe about how unfairly silenced
you are but remember
fascists do not actually value freedom
democracy or diversity
they only value the race the people the
nation
their long-term goal is a society where
there is no room for anyone who isn't
white
or even anyone who isn't a fascist to
exist so you can begrudgingly concede to
fascists their constitutional freedoms
but remember you shouldn't expect any
reciprocity from them
they do not care about diversity of
opinions that kind of talking point
is just deployed to protect fascist
recruitment and intimidation
and to garner sympathy from centrists
[Music]
oh fascist strategies work
because centrists are usually naive
about them they don't notice dog
whistles and usually give fascists the
benefit of the doubt
following politics with centrists can be
like watching a raunchy comedy movie
with children who don't get sexual
innuendo
there's a whole hidden layer of meaning
that they're not picking up this makes
liberals centrists and conservatives who
are not savvy to fascist strategy
easy to exploit time and time again such
people end up inadvertently spreading
around fascist memes and talking points
without intending to or realizing it and
then they end up bewildered when
leftists who recognize the dog whistles
take offense
now you might wonder well if fascists
disguise themselves and liberals
inadvertently duplicate fascist memes
that isn't just about everyone's suspect
aren't you in fact just a paranoid
leftist who thinks everyone is a nazi
well that's what they want you to think
they benefit from the confusion and the
appearance that the left is paranoid
i'll admit there are cases where i can't
tell if someone is genuinely alt-light
or if they're just an oblivious centrist
who picked up the talking points
likewise it can be impossible to tell
the difference between someone who is
alt-light but not an outright fascist
and a fascist who is concealing their
power level so in a sense
yes i am a little bit paranoid the other
day the aclu tweeted a picture of an
adorable blonde child with the caption
this is the future aclu members want and
for a second i was like
what the [ __ ] because it has a close
resemblance to a 14 words
meme but of course it's unintentional
it's the aclu
i wanted to make sure unlike most
politicians
that what i said was correct not make a
quick statement the statement i made on
saturday the first statement
was a fine statement but you don't make
statements
that direct unless you know the fact yes
i have become
crazy but this paranoia self-doubt and
questioning of your own perception
is the psychological consequence of
being constantly
gaslit by fascists pretending not to be
fascists and communicating in code
and it's the intentional consequence of
that gaslighting is just another tool in
the fascist's psychological arsenal
so how do we get better at resisting
fascist strategies
i know if you're a centrist who has
inadvertently repeated fascist rhetoric
or defended fascists
it seems like the left all thinks you're
a nazi and that we hate you
and i admit that i am pretty frustrated
with you right now
obviously but my forgiveness and
encouragement are wide open to anyone
who wants to get better at resisting
fascism
fascist strategies can be very subtle
and very cunning
so don't feel guilty for falling for
them just try to get better at resisting
i guess my message to liberals centrists
and non-fascist conservatives is this
if you care about even one person of
color or queer person
or immigrant stand up for that person by
opposing the alt-right and its allies
do not give them a platform do not host
debates with them on your youtube
channel
yes they have a constitutional right to
free speech but they do not have a right
to a megaphone and you should not be
giving them one
i know to a lot of you this just seems
like the free marketplace of ideas
everyone expressing their ideas
peacefully
but to more vulnerable people some ideas
can be existentially dangerous
because if those ideas catch on their
lives are at stake
now if you're just an average person
without a big platform then you actually
can debate and you should be debating
argue with your friends who are getting
kind of alt-righty argue with your
family argue with your co-workers
let them know that you don't agree make
them listen to a different perspective
and if you're someone who's gotten
involved with the alt-right in the last
couple years and is now disillusioned to
find yourself in the midst of a
dangerous hate group
you have to get out now it's not too
late society will forgive you
if you don't know how to leave look up
life after hate
an organization founded by a former
neo-nazi that helps people get out of
hate groups
and as for all you lefties
keep up the good fight comrades
[Music]
so
you